from acclaimed indie dramas to massive
Marvel blockbusters Mark Ruffalo has
proven he can do it all but that doesn't
mean that he nails every scene on the
first take and we've got just the
collection of hilarious bloopers to
prove it after a couple of false starts
with Eric Bana and Edward Norton Marvel
finally found a credible Hulk and Mark
Ruffalo well he has yet to get a
standalone movie he's been a big green
part of the Avengers films and has
popped up in a number of Marvel
Cinematic Universe entries while Hulk is
primarily the work of CGI Ruffalo does
the heavy lifting as the dr. Jekyll to
Hulk's mr. Hyde as gifted scientist
Bruce Banner your work on antielectron
collisions is unparalleled and I'm a
huge fan of the way you lose control and
turn into an enormous green rage monster
maybe it's because we won't like him
when he's angry or maybe it's because
the Hulk and Banner are two different
entities at the end of the day but
whatever the reason Ruffalo decided that
Hulk wasn't going to stick around to
Hulk smash this particular Avengers
scene dr. banner now it might be a
really good time for you to get angry
that's my secret that I'm always angry
this version on the other hand didn't
make the cut
[Music]
like the rest of his fellow Avengers and
the majority of the actors who've taken
on major roles in the MCU Ruffalo has to
cope with a certain amount of green
screen acting up to and including the
hours he spent on set playing the Hulk
via a motion capture rig that acts as
the basis for the CGI driven depiction
of the big green guy that we see on
screen but Ruffalo has it a little
easier than most given that he doesn't
often have to speak much while playing
the hole but that definitely isn't to
say he hasn't faced some of his own
dialogue challenges these Avengers
movies are at their core science fiction
flicks and he's playing the most
prominent scientist around in them that
means it's up to Ruffalo to deliver lots
of technical jargon and scientific word
gumbo and even an actor Ruffalo's
caliber has a tough time with it
sometimes potent cells inside a design
low plural potent cells into it his
Island sex look so was the third time
the charm polysaccharide the Avengers
movies offer an embarrassment of riches
when it comes to action stars so much of
their huge cast consists of established
veterans within the genre serving up the
physical skills necessary to bring those
superhero characters to life Scarlett
Johansson Chris Hemsworth Jeremy Renner
and Chris Evans among others have all
jumped kicked and punched their way
through other movies but not so much
Ruffalo bursts in theater he's more of a
words and face actor which are vital
when it comes to playing Bruce Banner
the human pre anger iteration of the
monstrous Hulk
that said he seemed to have a hard time
with a minor physical demands of his
role in Huah Ragnarok at least Thor is
there to rescue him despite his many
on-screen appearances as a superhero and
starring in three enjoyably ridiculous
movies about magicians now you see me
the Brothers Bloom and now you see me
too Ruffalo is widely regarded as a
serious actor that's probably because
his powerful work in affecting
award-winning dramas like the normal
hearts and spotlight overshadowed the
more privileged if financially
successful line items on his resume lark
would say
what's he get out of this he maintains a
quiet dignity and self-respect through
all his work so when a script requires
him to say something kind of stupid it's
a real treat falta here Ruffalo gets
silly and to see how he pulls it off
without looking bad well it turns out he
can't quite pull it off during a take on
13 going on 30 this was his big moment
you know what
Razzles Razzles and this was his epic
fail I could really use a razzle I
really need a razzle Ruffalo wasn't
always an a-list superhero and Reese
Witherspoon wasn't always a frequently
oscar-nominated actress and behind the
scenes boss of stuff like big little
lies in 2005 Ruffalo and Witherspoon
were both making a name for themselves
with romantic comedies particularly high
concept ones like Just Like Heaven
Witherspoon plays a doctor in a coma
whose spirit leaves her body to go haunt
her apartment where an apple bowl
Landscape Architect played by Ruffalo
has taken residence about what has it
crossed your mind that there might be
something a little off about the way
you've been spending your days
eventually Weatherspoon gets better and
they magically live happily ever after
but in this outtake Ruffalo comes on a
little too strong with his leading lady
here was his best take as anything
dramatic happened to really what
like dying baby don't you say that to me
and here was his worst remember anything
like dramatic happening to you recently
like what I don't know like dying baby
[Music]
while filming another scene from the
movie Ruffalo seemingly couldn't resist
delivering this improvised quip to his
scantily clad scene partner when his
very mid-2000 cell phone started ringing
[Music]
no I'm just happy to see you check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]